[Applause]
the Mayhem
they taught Motley Crue out of shred and
party they tattooed their name on me
when I was passed out what
these guys go hard I was in Collins the
first time I saw the Mayhem play I grew
up idolizing Dr T I bought gold grills
just to be like him
well we got a little sidetracked by the
80s
for sure a two three four I'm norrising
from Wax town records I would love to
help you make an album well all right
what's happening I think animal digs
yeah I dig the animal as well
waited my entire life for an Electric
Mayhem album finally somebody is making
it happen Okay it begins
they're a good animal
let's say we bring the old school and
you bring the news how about a hot music
collab huh I think animals all ready to
lay down our drum track
that was perfect
I don't think the band is digging any of
this it is
sure we did it see happy they're always
happy
watch hey guys look I got a fork
you did it
you'll shoot us there's a whole world
beyond the Mayhem it's trending you did
this
with one tweet you started beef with all
of music
and our Vengeance shall be Swift
I like this show lots of drama
let's get back to you doing what you do
best I'm ready to roll with it we're
good cause we're ready to rock with it
we're gonna rock
[Music]
into the Mayhem we were more than just a
band we're a family
Electric Mayhem is that a vacuum thank
you doesn't get any weirder than that am
I right you know it
[Music]
see this camera okay do not look into
this camera action
[Music]
talking about a cliffhanger Disney plus
is gonna love this
everybody watch